there are many pieces of literature that
tell the story of one's journey
in the afterlife for some dante's
inferno may be the first of these
classical pieces that comes to mind
even if it's not something you've read
you may still be familiar with the name
what some people may not know is that
it's just one part
of a three-part work written by dante
known as divinia comadia the divine
comedy
a narrative poem that follows the
concept of the journey one must take
after death as thought of by many during
the middle ages
we as the audience travel alongside
dante through hell
purgatory and heaven which are the three
segments of this narrative
inferno purgatorio and paradiso
it's a story that certainly gives you an
interesting insight into the social
conditions and
expectations during the middle ages
and if you also happen to be a fan of
greek and roman mythology
dante does not shy away from showing its
influence on his own work
there are references upon references
upon references
but as we are talking about a piece of
work that was written in the 14th
century
some of the language used means it's not
the easiest
or most fun read however at its core
i believe it's a story well worth
sharing
and so in today's video we will explore
and summarize the first
part of dante's journey the nine
circles of hell
before we delve any deeper today's video
has been made possible by the great
courses
plus the goal of this channel has always
been to share
interesting stories whether it's myths
and legends or more traditional fiction
my primary focus has always been to
entertain and to shed light on forgotten
tales
if these videos intrigue you enough to
go and do additional research
and learn new things then my job here is
mostly done
the only question left is where can i
continue this learning
and that is where i can strongly
recommend the great courses plus
an on-demand subscription-based learning
service that you can access
on your phone tablet and computer
i'm sure given the current situation
many of us have exhausted the streaming
services of
everything worth watching so rather than
sifting through
hours of terrible television you should
head over to the great courses plus
where they have over 11 000 courses
lectures
and documentaries on pretty much
everything
from history science and philosophy to
food travel and finance it's all there
presented by
ivy league professors who are far more
intelligent
and eloquent than myself you're free to
learn at your own pace
in the comfort of your home without the
stress of deadlines and exams
for those of you still looking for your
mythology fix
i've recently started the great
mythologies of the world
a 60 part series which covers all sorts
of myths
from all around the globe i've only just
got into egypt and there's still
so much left to cover if you're
interested in learning about some of the
lesser-known mythologies then
this is a course for you if you'd like
to try the great courses plus for
yourself
you can use my link over at
www.thegreatcoursesplus.com
mythology or you can click on the link
in the description of this video and
start your free trial today
it's a great way to support the channel
while still learning new things
and being productive
the story is set in the year 1300
dante wakes up on the evening of good
friday
in a dark wood with no recollection of
how he got there
in the distance he can see a foothill
a mountain where the sun shines bright
he decides it must be safer than the
wood
and so he starts his ascent but as he
climbs he encounters a leopard
and then a lion and then a she-wolf
overwhelmed by these animals he has no
choice but to turn
back to the forest here he comes across
a spirit known as virgil
a once famous poet or bard
he tells dante that he can guide him to
paradise
but first they must journey through hell
dante himself
also a storyteller immediately feels
this connection to virgil
and so he trusts him as a guide
together they pass through the gates of
hell and begin their journey
as one would imagine this is not a
pleasant place
a place where all hope is abandoned
a city of eternal woe and pain
the sky was pitch black but not a single
star could be
seen the air was thick with the moans of
grief and sorrow
dante recounts seeing a flag whirling
through the air being followed by a
train of naked spirits
these unfortunate souls were cursed to
chase this unattainable flag while being
stung
by wasps and hornets the tears they
wept and the blood from their wounds
dripped onto their feet
and the ground was covered in maggots
and worms
the only way to escape this torment is
to journey
deeper into hell and the only way to do
that
is to cross the river acheron when they
reach the riverbank
there are countless souls waiting for
caron the ferryman of the dead
we can immediately see the influence of
greek mythology on dante here
the river acheron running through the
underworld and
karon being the ferryman of the dead are
taken straight out of greek myth
caron eventually agrees to take them
across the river in his boat
when they arrive on the other side
virgil explains to dante that this
is the first circle of hell known as
limbo the souls who reside here were not
necessarily bad people in terms of sins
committed
but they did not possess the necessary
faith many of them
rejected christianity the unbaptized and
virtuous pagans
is how they described they may not have
been sinful but they were still
sentenced to an eternity of damnation
and denied
entry into paradise in the distance
there is a large citadel which houses
many of the great philosophers plato
socrates
aristotle and many more before becoming
dante's guide this was also the home of
virgil
and dante does also come across other
great poets such as homer
ovid and horace there are also many
great greek and roman
musicians statesmen generals and
physicians
eventually they depart and make their
way onwards to the
second circle of hell lust
the first circle was undoubtedly a
punishment
but those who resided there still had
some freedom
the second circle onwards is where the
real punishment began
there to greet souls as they entered the
second circle
was minos a giant serpentine
figure in greek myth minos was the son
of zeus
and the first king of crete after his
death he would become one of the three
judges of
hades in dante's interpretation he
certainly has a much more
monstrous form minos would examine the
crimes of those born before him
and give them a sentence that he felt
was fitting
he would wrap his tail around himself a
certain amount of times
and that number would determine which
circle they were sentenced to
the second circle of hell was intended
for those who had succumbed to lust
and many of these were kings queens and
rulers
such as cleopatra helen of troy paris
and achilles dante views lust
as a mutual indulgence and therefore
sees it
as the least heinous of sins the
punishment is also the most lenient
inside of hell itself
with help from virgil dante is allowed
past minos
and they enter the third circle of hell
gluttony here there is an icy rain that
never stops
as punishment for their insatiable
appetites
the gluttonous are left to wallow and
squirm around in the vile
and putrid mud like worms
gelatinous masses unable to stand or
even crawl
guarding them is the three-headed hound
cerberus
who patrols up and down this filthy mire
flaying and mauling the gluttonous with
his claws
tearing their spirits as they helplessly
scream
luckily virgil manages to calm cerberus
and they are able to pass safely through
they come across a few spirits who have
suffered in this circle for some time
these unfortunate souls no longer have
bodies
and resemble not much more than
foul-smelling liquid
dante then meets a spirit that he
doesn't recognize
called chiako chiako however recognizes
dante from back home in
florence he also gives him the first of
many political prophecies
or predictions he inquires about the
state of civil conflict within
florence and then tells dante that the
party he aligns with will be expelled
with aid from rome
in the fourth circle of hell dante
encounters a figure
known as pluto a deity of
wealth we soon discover that this is the
circle
of greed where those who cared too much
for material goods would be punished
they are divided into two separate
groups
the first consisted of those who would
hoard their possessions and money
the second consisted of those who spent
their money freely
neglected the value of their possessions
and squandered
everything they had these two groups
were cursed to push
enormous weights up a hill only to meet
each other in the middle
where they would argue why do you hoard
one group would ask why do you waste
the other would respond when they
clashed in the middle they would knock
each other and the weights down
to the bottom only to repeat the process
again
and again the hoarders and wasters are
housed together as a punishment
forever arguing and screaming never
listening or trying to understand the
other's perspective a pretty accurate
description of today's society sadly
as they descend deeper they reach the
river styx and the fifth circle of hell
wrath the river is more of a
swampy mire where the wrathful fight and
battle
the boatman known as flyligus arrives
and
after a short disagreement with virgil
he agrees to ferry them to the other
side
as they journey across the marsh a soul
jumps up and grabs the boat
filippo argenti a bitter political rival
of dante back in florence
the two exchanged some rather harsh
words and dante wishes for felipo
to suffer more punishment ironically
dante's behavior here
is not too different from the souls that
reside in this circle
in the far distance dante notices fiery
towers
and burning wars virgil explains that
they are approaching the
city of dis in the lower portion of hell
where the heretics are housed when they
arrive
they are denied entry by the fallen
angels who guard the gates
they grant virgil passage with only one
condition
that he may never return to his own
circle
it's at this point dante begins to worry
that he may never leave hell
himself virgil agrees to enter alone
and open the gates from the inside for
dante
but in this task he is unsuccessful
he returns to dante with the angel
slamming the gate shut
behind him but he vows to dante that he
will
not abandon him despite both poets being
terrified virgil
is adamant that their journey shall
continue
for the first time dante starts to doubt
his guide
having seen virgil fail it's also
apparent
that he has no real plan and things can
only get worse he asks virgil
if he's ever been this deep into hell
before
and virgil replies that he has ventured
this deep into hell
once before when the sorceress erikso
sent him to retrieve a soul for one of
her necrotic
rituals all of a sudden out of nowhere
appeared the furies
three female figures stained in blood
with serpents entwined around their
bodies
electo meguera and tisiphony
they were far from pleased to see dante
and decided to summon medusa to turn him
into stone
virgil warns dante of medusa's gaze and
covers his eyes to ensure he isn't
turned into stone
and trapped in hell forever from the
river styx
emerges a figure that virgil recognizes
and he tells dante to bow and remain
quiet
as the angelic figure approaches it
becomes clear that it was sent from
heaven
the furies immediately flee in terror
and the angels who denied
entry are reprimanded the angel then
does what virgil could not
and opens the gates allowing the two
poets to enter
the city of dis or the city of
dieter contains circles six through nine
with circle six being located just
within its walls
and the rest closer to the center
in the circle of heresy dante and virgil
come across
a group of heretics who have been locked
inside burning tombs
as punishment these were known as the
epicureans
a sex of people who believed when the
body died
so did the soul and so they valued
pleasure
above all else as it allowed them to
enter a state of tranquility
so they lived their lives believing
pleasure allowed them to escape
all sorts of pain and discomfort which
makes their punishment in hell
all the more ironic dante comes across
two of the tortured souls
one of which is from florence but once
again
is on the opposite side of dante
before leaving this region the poets
experienced the most
vile smell imaginable permeating from
the lower regions
a smell so bad they had to stop and rest
virgil takes this time to explain what
they will encounter next
the next three circles contain smaller
circles
inside themselves the circle of violence
for example
is divided into three sections in the
first you have those who commit an
acts of violence against others and
their property
in the second you have those who
committed acts of violence
against themselves such as suicide
and lastly you have those who committed
acts of violence
against god or nature as their time
shortens they must descend into circle
seven
the circle of violence before entering
the circle they must pass
a narrow passage of broken rocks
here they encounter the minotaur who
blocks their path
virgil begins to mock the creature
asking if its murderer can also be found
in the circle
of violence sending it into a blind rage
the minotaur charges and ends up
severely wounded
rendering itself unable to continue
giving chase to the poets
the first section of circle seven is
reserved for those who committed acts of
violence
against their fellow man there is a
river of boiling blood that these souls
must wade through
every day the level of blood one is
submerged in
is dependent on the severity of the
crime
those who committed murder would be
fully submerged
whereas someone who committed assault
may only be submerged
partially as they approach the river
they see it's guarded by
a group of centaurs who immediately
point their bows at dante and virgil
demanding to know what business they
have here
virgil then tells them he will only
speak to their leader
these centaurs guard the river not to
stop individuals like dante and virgil
from
entering but to stop the souls of this
circle from escaping the river itself
when chiron notices that dante is not
actually dead
he draws his bow and demands virgil
explains their story
he agrees for the centaurs to take the
poets to a shallow point in the river
and allow them to cross on one of these
centaur's backs
the centaur chosen for this task is
nessus
which is very ironic in itself because
in greek myth
nessus was a centaur who agreed to take
heracles and his wife
across a river when he crossed the river
with heracles wife he then forced
himself upon her
and left heracles no choice but to kill
him
in dante's story there is no betrayal
from nessus
he does as he was instructed and ferries
the two poets across the river
after crossing the river of blood they
walk through a wood
the trees in this wood are gnarled and
twisted
with no leaf in sight all around him
dante his moans and shrieks but other
than the two poets there is no one else
in this word
weary that there may be terrors hiding
dante urges virgil to tread quietly
but virgil knows where these noises are
coming from
virgil breaks a branch off the tree and
to dante's surprise blood
pours from the branch and the tree cries
out in pain
oh why have you come to cause me
pain i was once a man just like
you the second part of this circle
is reserved for those who committed
suicide
as they did not value their bodies in
life that in hell
those bodies would be taken away every
day harpies would swoop down to claw
and feed off the trees only when they
were broken and bleeding were they
permitted to speak virgil explains that
he meant the tree
no harm but witnessing it firsthand was
the only way dante would believe him
he asked the tree to tell dante his
story
he was once a man named pietro de la
vina
a diplomat under the service of
frederick the second king of sicily
he was a reputable man with status until
he was accused of treason
and locked away watching as his good
fortune turned to grief was too much for
pietro
and so he took his own life dante
determines that this man
must have been wrongfully accused and
convicted
otherwise he would have been in the
circle for traitors
but the fact that he is here with others
who committed suicide
means he must have been an honest man
led down a dark path by
others and so he returns the twigs and
branches broken by virgil
and they move on the third part of this
circle is a desolate
barren plain where flakes of fire fell
from the sky
it housed those who committed violence
against art
nature and god the souls found here were
subjected to a
burning heat the blasphemers who
committed crimes against god
were laid out onto the burning sand
while fire rained down on them
unable to move the sodomites who harm
nature were left to run around the
desert through the lava-like sand
those who committed crimes against art
were left
huddled together all three of these
groups were perpetually screaming out in
pain
as the ashy flakes fell to the ground
and caught fire
leaving these sinners to experience an
eternal burning
the two poets traveled through the
desert waving away flakes of fire
whenever they fell near them
trying their best and not to catch fire
dante stops when he sees a man who isn't
crying out in pain
the fire doesn't seem to bother him at
all as he lays in the sand
this man is kaepernius during the siege
of thebes he stood on a ladder
over the walls and screamed that not
even
zeus himself could stop him entering and
laying waste to the city
of course arrogance and hubris of this
kind would not be tolerated by
zeus who then killed kaepernius of a
thunderbolt
proving that he could indeed stop him
from entering the city
in dante's story kaepanis is in this
circle of hell for blasphemy against
jupiter or jove the equivalent to zeus
who also struck him down with a bolt of
thunder
he chose no remorse for his sin as he
lay there in the burning sand
cursing the name of the god who struck
him down
as they continue on they come across a
stream covered in a
thick mist which offers them protection
from the fire above
along this stream dante is recognized by
a man who is
completely covered in burns this man
is brunetto latini dante's mentor
and guardian when his father passed away
he asked dante if he may walk with him
and dante eagerly accepts suggesting
that maybe they should sit down so they
can catch up
brunetto however tells dante that he
cannot
because of his sins he must never stop
wandering the desert
so far we've only really seen political
enemies of dante in hell
but brunetto is one of the first spirits
he meets from back in florence who
shares his political beliefs
he even warns him that he faces exile if
he somehow escapes hell
and returns to florence they would
eventually come to the end of the stream
and in front of them was the edge of a
cliff and a roaring waterfall below
dante sees three men in front of him
that he recognizes from
florence they ask him not to judge them
based on their burnt and scarred
appearance
for they were once famous and esteemed
to men
as they were guilty of sodomy they could
not stop walking
and so they formed a circle around dante
asking him of the current political
situation in florence
a question that leaves dante with an
expression of grief
he then tells them the story of his
journey and they wish him luck
if he ever escapes hell they ask only
that he speaks of them
favorably as they look down into the
abyss below
virgil asked dante to throw the belt he
wore around his waist
over the edge and weight they are now
approaching the eighth
circle of hell a strange shape that
dante can't quite make out
rises from below and stops before them
behold the beast with a pointed tail
that crosses
mountains leaves walls and weapons
broken
and makes the stench of which the world
is full
the creature answers virgil's call and
makes itself visible
a creature with human bestial and
reptilian elements all combined into one
its name is garyon a winged monster with
the face of a man
a scorpion stinger and a body that is
part
beast part reptile its general shape can
be compared to that of a wyvern
with some elements of a chimera or
manticore
in greek myth garyon is a three-headed
giant
but here dante's garyon is an
amalgamation of three separate beings
and is a visual representation of the
next circle
the friendly human face makes him seem
trustworthy
but his grotesque body and stinger
present us with the idea of a trickster
or fraudster behind the pleasant face
is a cold-blooded monster virgil
explains the only way down this
waterfall is on the creature's back
but he makes sure that he sits behind
dante
and warns him to be wary of gary on
stinger
those who are not wary of his true
nature never make it to the bottom of
this abyss
the eighth circle of hell is fraud for
those who committed
fraudulent and malicious crimes
this circle is also known as the
malibulger
meaning the ditches of evil this also
refers to the layout of the circle
as it's divided into ten narrow ditches
each one punishing a different
act of fraud the first ditch contains
seducers and panderers a fancy name for
a
pimp or someone who owns a brothel these
two groups lined the walls of this ditch
walking in opposite directions being
whipped
by horned demons at first this may not
seem like a
harsh punishment but these demons can be
seen
as symbolic of slave drivers just as
these men
chose to treat women like objects that
could be disposed of and
sold in the afterlife they would be
nothing more than a commodity themselves
to these demonic slave drivers
dante recognizes one man as venedicio
who he recalls arranged the sale of his
own sister to a nobleman
on the other side virgil points out a
man named
jason jason of argo the once famous hero
jason is there for the seduction of the
sorceress madea
which to be fair had more to do with
athena and
hera trying to help him but he did also
seduce the queen of lemnos and then
sail away after she had two of his
children so for that douchebaggery jason
is condemned to an eternity in hell
next to this trench are those considered
guilty of
false flattery exploiting others fears
and desires by
twisting and corrupting language to
manipulate them
these individuals are covered in their
own feces which represent the falsehoods
they told whilst alive
they do nothing but writhe around and
howl at each other
not a sight dante and virgil were keen
on observing for very long
in the third ditch dante finds those
guilty of
simony gaining position in the christian
church
due to monetary means or through other
favors
this term comes from simon magnus a
magician
or sorcerer who tried to pay saint peter
to bestow the power of the holy spirit
upon him
the simonix as they are referred to were
placed headfirst into holes
with flames burning the soles of their
feet
dante notices one pair of feet squirming
more than the others because the flames
are much higher
this soul was pope nicholas iii who
mistakes dante for the then
pope bonifacio he explains to dante that
because he tried to abuse his position
in the church
he must serve a lifetime in this hall
and below him are all the other popes
guilty of the same crime
when the next pope dies he will take his
place at the very
top pushing pope nicholas further down
the hole
like all those before him the corruption
of the church by the simon axe is
something dante makes very clear he
despises
which is why we see it so deep into hell
in the fourth hole were the sorcerers
who dabbled in divination
fortune telling and astrology arts that
were associated with a
false prophet the punishment for being a
sorcerer was having their head twisted
backwards
leaving them to slowly walk forward and
only being able to look back
at the other hideous distorted sorcerers
in the fifth hole were the berettas also
known
as grifters these souls are immersed in
a
lake of boiling tar a visual
representation of their shady dealings
and sticky fingers
they are also guarded by winged demons
known
as the malibrange when a grifter tries
to emerge from the surface
they claw at them and attack them with
hooks until they are once again
fully submerged for some reason dante
ends up insulting these demons which
results in them being pursued
they eventually escape down a slope
where they encounter hole number six
these men are dressed in what appear to
be regular robes
but judging by how slowly they're moving
and the discomfort in their face
this isn't true these robes are weighed
down by
lead on the outside everything looks
fine
these robes appear just as you would
expect from any holy man
but the weight inside is symbolic of the
weight
one carries with them in lies and deceit
dante and virgil climb across a ruined
bridge
and stand above pit number seven this
hole
is full of naked people being chased by
snakes and lizards
their hands are bound behind their backs
with snakes
these souls are the thieves those who
stole in life will now have
everything stolen from them their
possessions
their identity and their humanity
dante finds one man willing to tell him
his story
vani fucci a man who stole holy items
from a cathedral
who committed violent crimes and murder
as they talk a viper bites his neck
and kills vanny only for him to burst
into flames
and resurrect from the ashes like a
phoenix
vani shares a prophecy with dante that
all those dante aligns with
back in florence shall die including
dante
as the snake attacks him again vani
curses the gods and
flees from dante after this a
centaur arrives with a fire breathing
dragon on his shoulder
and he asks where the bitter one has
gone
implying that he is there to punish vani
dante wonders why the other centaurs in
hell watch over the river of blood but
this one known as
cassis finds himself with the other
thieves
virgil explains that this is because
cassis was killed by heracles when he
tried to steal his cattle
so although centaurs by nature are
violent
this one was also a thief they also
observe
quite a disturbing process where a snake
with feet
bites a man and then the two begin to
merge together
and mutate into one creature with body
parts from both
another snake bites a man and smoke paws
from his wound
and the snake's mouth this time the two
swap places
and mutate into each other the man's
body
shrinks and distorts until he becomes a
snake
and the snake subsequently becomes a man
giving us the impression that everything
in this hole
may be a thief even these snakes and
lizards we thought existed in the whole
to
punish the thieves in hole 8
dante sees the fraudulent counsellors
who are literally burning in a pit of
flames for their sins
these are individuals who use their
positions to convince
and manipulate others to engage in fraud
here we notice two heroes in particular
odysseus
and diomedes who were held accountable
for the idea of the trojan
horse as well as numerous other failings
that led to the fall of troy
the ninth hole was dedicated to the
sowers of discord
those who tried to create divisions
between people
when dante looks down into the pit he
struggles to find words to describe
what he sees those guilty of creating
these divisions were being
hacked away by a demon wielding a large
blood-stained sword their bodies were
torn into pieces
entrails were dragged along the floor
and most bodies no longer even resembled
a human
shape just as they sought to tear others
apart in life
in death their bodies are physically
torn apart and mutilated
dante eventually describes this by
saying
if you gathered all the people who were
injured in the bloodiest
and most grotesque battles their wounds
and injuries could still not match the
mutilation that took place
in the ninth hull when their bodies were
torn apart they would drag themselves
around this hull
regenerating once a full circuit was
complete
the demon would then tear them apart
again and this cycle would repeat for
eternity
dante unable to shake what he saw from
his mind
approached the tenth and final hull
from this hole came a horrendous stench
bodies were scattered around laying on
top of each other
disease ridden and writhing
these bodies belonged to the falsifiers
the alchemists
the counterfeiters and the imposters
just as they were a plague on humanity
in life they experienced
every plague and disease possible dante
noticed some of them were covered in
leperous scabs
furiously scratching until there was no
flesh remaining
after everything dante has seen and been
through
he finally approaches a giant well
the entrance to the final circle of hell
the circle of treachery
outside they see numerous giants
one blowing on a horn was nimrod who
built
the tower of babel in hell however he is
incapable of
coherent speech next to him is a much
larger giant in chains effie eltes
who was punished for his uprising
against jove
this is referring to the gigantomachy
where the
giants tried to storm olympus leading
this army against
zeus was ephelte's another giant who
isn't
in chains is antaeus and it's this giant
who places both poets
in the palm of his hand and carries them
down to the ninth circle
and so the last part of dante's journey
through hell
begins in a circle he describes as the
bottom of the universe
full of treachery and betrayal
at the very bottom they come across
another lake
but there is no blood or tar
this lake has frozen over it spans
almost the entirety of the
circle and is divided into four sections
with the sinners being trapped in the
ice itself
these are known as the betrayers of
family
community the guests and lords
dante then describes two immediate
regions
the first is known as kana which is
referring to the biblical figure
kane who kills his own brother no
surprise this area houses
those who betrayed their family these
sinners
are not fully submerged in the ice they
can still move their heads
but nothing else dante sees two bodies
frozen
so close together that their foreheads
are almost glued by the cold
and he recognizes them as two brothers
who murdered each other
over a dispute involving family
inheritance
the second area is known as antenora
named after the trojan soldier antenor
who betrayed his people to the greeks
this area housed those who committed
treason and betrayed their country
and community as dante continues across
this lake he
accidentally kicks someone in the head
and they shout back asking
why do you trample me the bodies in this
area are submerged in a similar way to
the previous
the main difference being they can't
move their neck
the man who dante kicked was someone who
betrayed florence
and dante gives this man no apology or
sympathy
the third region in this icy wasteland
is ptolemy
named after a man who invited his
father-in-law to dinner
only to kill him dante stumbles upon a
man who asked him if he can remove the
ice from his eyes
the man then explains that after
murdering a guest
the soul falls into ptolemy long before
the body dies
the empty body is then inhabited by a
demon
until a natural death occurs so their
suffering begins
long before they actually die the fourth
area of this lake
is known as judeka of course being named
after judas
and those who betrayed the lord those in
judeka
are fully encased in the ice and as a
result
not a sound is made as there is no one
to speak to
the poets move quickly on to the center
of hell
virgil tells dante that the banner of
the king of hell draws closer
meaning there is only one soul left to
observe
when they reach the very center dante is
frozen to the spot
and no words can be formed in the very
center of hell
satan is condemned for the worst act of
all
treachery against god himself
it's explained here that his name was
once lucifer
the fairest of the angels in heaven but
his rebellion against god
led to him being cast from heaven and
frozen in ice from the waist
down dante struggles to comprehend how
big
lucifer's body really is only being able
to see the upper half which is free from
ice
what's more stunning than his size is
the fact that he has
three heads one that is fiery red
one that is pale yellow and one that is
black
underneath each head are a pair of
bat-like
wings which have been flapping and
causing the icy winds
dante and virgil experienced while
crossing the lake
these wings are also to ensure the lake
stays frozen
so satan and everybody else can never
leave this
prison satan himself cannot speak
but only cry and blubber into his mouth
each mouth is also
constantly chewing on a treacherous man
marcus junius brutus and gaius
cassius longinus two men responsible for
the assassination of julius caesar
hang from the left and right mouths
in the center mouth hangs judas punished
for his betrayal of jesus christ
judah suffered the worst punishment as
he represented treason against the
divine
whereas the others were guilty of
treason against man
virgil tells dante that now is when they
escape hell
by climbing down lucifer himself which
makes no sense to dante as surely that
would only take them
deeper into hell virgil assures him that
this is the only way
and so they climb down satan's legs once
they reach his genitalia they pass
through the center of the universe
virgil turns his body around and then
starts climbing
back up which again makes no sense to
dante as that's the way they just came
from
as dante follows virgil he's amazed to
see everything is essentially
upside down and they are now climbing up
lucifer's legs
virgil explains that they are
essentially climbing up through the
crater left by lucifer when he crashed
into the earth
they eventually climb out of hell on the
morning of easter sunday
and before them is the river lethe which
flows from the mountain of purgatory
i'm sure you've gathered where dante's
journey will take him next
unfortunately that is a journey for
another time
i hope you've enjoyed dante's inferno if
you'd like to see part two in purgatory
then
leave the video a like and let me know
in the comment section
as always i've been your host mythology
and fiction explained
you